outlook beta Zeta doesn't matter you
have to do to know can you talk about
where that idea was born from it was
actually born there was no very much
time between the end of season 3 and
beginning of season 4 we had to come up
with ideas really quickly and I was
sitting around with my brothers during
Christmas and we were reminiscing and
lamenting the fact we were so poor or 20
and didn't know realize how poor we were
being raised by a single mom and I
wanted to take it back to those sort of
spielberg Ian type struggles you see in
like et where the kids and the single
or really more and they had to have very
human struggles and for us in the
writers away to get back to human and
we've been working like a half it feels
like working what is the deal with
styles and are they dating they're
unique they're unlike most relationships
in high school I think they're do that
sex is good
I can say for upcoming they may have a
rocky road ahead it's gonna get its
gonna get difficult for Malia and Stiles
especially as a certain secret about her
parentage comes out now who knows what
that secret news feel like as a huge
secret that he's keeping from everyone
which we found out in last week's
episode what was your reaction when you
found out your character was slowly
losing all of his powers for me it was
actually really exciting it was kind of
an opportunity to I think anytime you
come across something with your
character that you can personally relate
to and like a very real way is always
really exciting so for me Derek becoming
more human was much the same this I went
through when I ever stopped my base walk
that was a huge identity thing for me as
a kid growing up that mine stops I kind
of so for Derek to be losing his powers
as a werewolf he's gonna have to figure
out who he is when he's now so it's
becoming a human and moving on and
finding your identity and you know who
you are what you stand for and the
actions you take
what did you sort of talk about what's
coming up in the next stretch a lot of
decision-making a lot of character arcs
coming to a finish I could say you saw
you saw here hail at the end of that
trailer and
one of the last line it says is it was
my bite that changed your life it's my
bike that can end it so you're gonna be
seeing the fruition of Peter Hales plan
and what he intends with Scott no that
was the first time you see him as a wolf
other than the Alpha yeah yeah it was a
big CGI monster before yes he was he's
never even has never worn the werewolf
makeup before other than that moment it
was just a CGI monster does anybody care
for you to audition for the show not
onee I mean for me what drew me to the
audition is that it was the sky as the
lead character I had never played a lead
before so I was like hell yeah it was on
MTV although I grew up watching MTV I
read the script it was phenomenal Jeff
Davis and everything everything was just
exactly the way I wanted to be and then
I met Dillman and Tyler and I was like
oh hell yeah I have to be a part of this
and there's been history ever since and
now where we make out all the time we
don't
we just sit next to each other in
underwear I love the script and I loved
styles and I want to join Edition for me
yeah I like the scripts I was the first
thing that caught my attention and then
I loved how was a creepy Derek West
actually straight your natural rebel I
know yes yeah yeah that was a family
joke going into a dying to be a werewolf
at some point in my life so this works
out nicely my audition and I was like
wait you worthy to be on this show
because I I knew him before the show and
so naturally you know I I was giving him
like tourist points to hit Atlanta
Murray's to film and that's an I gotta
colic you're gonna be a big model operas
of Milan and if I don't look Italian and
I'm five three and as some of you might
heard the story I somehow I'm gonna play
video Jeff Davis and thank you for
hiring the redhead pale short girl to
play so I have this weird secret hidden
talent where I can roll my arse
backwards so I was wondering in weird
by Betty um open web would you like that
I'm like trying to find some now that
may have been the hardest question I
could escape warning we can't do
anything don't let you do the work what
happened you don't me to do we can
answer a question without answering
like any supernatural character in the
history of super nasty edges or within
the world of team anyone okay next
question I can see your book ladies you
know spider-man Oh always it forever or
Chewbacca do you know if he ever saw
deeper and wider you wanna show us
comedic relief but offset visit villain
or I don't think between even though I
start masturbating and proving a lot we
have very different sensory differences
a few MERS on the set with a book it's
like offset it's like an ensemble sitcom
the truth so like what's called a kimono
going to be or buddy your personal like
models to calm you down when you're
talking to people your own
you know we've been talking a lot in the
writers room about stilinski and Melissa
they do have a certain chemistry don't
they I kind of I kind of shift styles of
Kate though I was like a you know cage
open look
originally I thought it'd be a really
cool a really funny scene if she had
like get information at me so she like
made out which is so easy than me the
conversations we had season one we all
live together amazing thank you to the
team we'll cast so much for being